and we're back same bat-time same
bat-channel
so yeah animation junkie not with the
green screen with a sidekick this time
this will be a first
possibly and only we'll see how bad it
goes I mean case you folks don't know
this is my friend Brian Daly he
sometimes shows up for the council geeks
roundtable talks and we just finished
watching Batman return of the Caped
Crusader's I've been depressed a lot
this week just some stuff going on in
the world and everywhere and I didn't
know if there was a form of escapism
that could actually take me out of that
and make me feel good this did it is the
60s Batman show taken to an extreme that
they only could not do at the time
because they couldn't afford to do what
what they're able to do in animation
right but everything that goes on in it
is true to that show it absolutely is
and the script for this thing is
incredible like everything from the the
the hyperbolic dialogue you know like
there's so much alliteration dumptrucks
alliteration and adjectives and adverbs
not everything that they just throw into
this thing and it's lovingly crafted it
is like a love letter to this but it
doesn't feel like an outsider's take on
this it never feels like it's mocking
the source material it pushes certain
things slightly hardened that like it
pulls a few more jokes would say the
Zach pal sure things like they had it's
a spork they're pushing the buttons a
little but they're never it's never a
mockery it's not pointing at and going
man this was dumb it's pointy and it
going man this was great right and let's
just do it a little harder
I think things flew over my head I think
there were some inside jokes that I
missed I think there were some gags that
might have made it a little bit harder
if I was freshly immersed in this series
but you didn't need to come into this
with prerequisite knowledge
you didn't I mean to see where I'm
coming from I never saw the egghead
episode but I know about it I never saw
the back to see episode but I know about
it so just knowing that stuff gives you
basically the ammunition you need to did
soak all this up right right and I think
they probably had in mind that if you
had only seen the movie which is pretty
readily available yeah you can get this
I mean that's why they chose the
villains that they chose they went with
the quartet of Joker Riddler penguin
Catwoman it was the same group of
villains from that movie obviously the
the actors who are still alive which are
Burt Burt Ward Adam well Adam West and
Julie Newmar and Julie Newmar as
Catwoman they were brought back before
we get to them what were your thoughts
on the ones who are obviously doing
imitations so I we were getting people
doing imitations of Frank gorshins
Riddler and burgess Meredith very
sanguine and Cesar Romero yeah I like to
all of them well one thing that I did
mention to you was I felt like the The
Joker for I think they got the laughs
pretty well and there were a few lines
where I was like that and that feels
very much like Cesar Romero but there
were just times where I felt like I was
like this feels like they're doing an
impression of a Spanish accent that
they're trying to hide as amount of
Spanish accent which considering we've
never got a close-up where you can see a
mustache I was I was yeah I kept hope
made me to me that was like the next
best thing I was like this sounds like
that tried to be a Spanish actor trying
not to sound like a Spanish actor stuff
there there was enough of it or I was
like that's a weird enough voice that it
did feel appropriate I don't know if
it's as authentic as it could be but it
felt right well I heard some authentic I
thought the the Riddler was there crazy
off to the game sounded just sounded
just like Gorshin as for the penguin
it's a burgess Meredith voice and that
was really easy to copy I think anybody
couldn't kind of do any mention of that
Meredith UM's elbows had a really heavy
affectation really nice it's always
easier to do an impression of a put-on
voice than do an impression of
somebody's natural voice like
Commissioner Gordon
oh did the chief O'Hara just again the
hell is one word they were like boy
we're coming really close to just making
fun of you but again if loving I'm not
sure I want to talk too much about the
plot because they one of the fun things
for me was sort of seeing where it went
yeah because one of the concerns I had
going in was are they gonna get a
feature length out of this can people
who didn't actually write this stuff at
the time and are basically doing fan
fiction can they string that for a
feature-length film and I think they did
I I was I think it felt like there was
an extra act tacked on at the end oh
yeah there were three parts where I felt
like they'd logically could have wrapped
it up and then they just said nope we're
not quite done we're gonna do another
thing well they had really felt like it
was the climax of the story pretty much
straight had been building to write and
then I had about another 10 minutes
after that yeah moving chase bells yeah
it could have been cut it Ronnie it
wasn't bad I think it's the latest
iteration of what I think is the most
consistent weakness is with the DC
animated films which is they're very
stringent about a 75 minute running time
and I've seen that hurt movies in both
directions I have seen movies that would
have been better done in short form had
it out with stuff that didn't work
The Killing Joke being the best example
of that and I've seen other stories that
would have been better if they just put
in five you know five ten more minutes
where the sub to let stuff breathe just
a little bit flashpoint paradox I think
is a good example of that one I'll get
back to the voice actors the three
returning cast yes Adam West forward
Julie Newmar I will say I think of the
three Julie Newmar was the weakest link
she what she was so good but I think um
well I think for one thing I don't know
if she's done much voice acting there
was something about her deliver on some
lines not all of them but on sunlights
it felt like she she like she wasn't
quite in the moment because she wasn't
there physically and I will say
her Catwoman and some of her dialogue
was mounted yes they had so much fun
writing Catwoman I guess it was just a
thing where I could I could kind of hear
the age of the actress and I was just
like that that the sound of her voice
just the pitched everything doesn't
match what I'm seeing
hmm and at first there were times in the
beginning when we were looking at Bruce
Wayne and Dick Grayson the out of
costume where I thought the same was
going to be true for Batman and Robin
like there were a few times where I was
like boy I'm not sure if these are gonna
sound right but maybe that like that
kind of feeling only lasted like the
first two or three minutes is he got a
climate of pretty quick now I I will say
that Adam West does sound Oliver than he
did the time but he's supposed to be
comparatively older anyway so it still
works Burt Ward sounded like he was
still 16 years old
ie for as much as he sounded like a 16
yeah he sounded as much of a teenager
now as he did 50 years ago holy crap
yeah neither of those two have lost
anything in terms of their delivery know
they know exactly how to read those
lines and exactly how to make the work
even especially in the case of Batman
even as the character was brought into
things to do things that he never did
know other than feeling like it might
have gone a little bit too long and I
really think that might be my only
complaint with and that is my only
complaint even what I felt like it went
too long it wasn't boring no endeavored
like lost my interest not to say that
things too long is that the way that it
space did hit its natural end before the
end of run time great time and I would
highly recommend it definitely one of
the much better times that I've had with
anything that's come out of DC animation
lately this is the antidote to everyday
everything that was wrong with The
Killing Joke so this this was wonderful
yeah I agree
so thank you for well thanks for coming
on don't know if I'll ever have anyone
on for animations argue review again but
thanks for joining me Ryan thank you and
I guess that'll wrap it up folks so as
for me I will be back as soon as I can
get my next fix